uh thank you all for being here for this
third talk right before lunch
um just a quick note after this uh after
this talk there'll be lunch in the
hallways outside so please take some
time to enjoy something to eat and take
a break
um and mingle with all of the attendees
and speakers here today so uh for this
talk we have uh Gill
um who will be starting us out with a
talk on Ibis so thank you thank you
uh good morning still everyone nice to
see you all thanks for coming
um
my name is Gail Forsyth I work at
Voltron data that's some of the places
you can find me on the internet my
colleague Philip Cloud will be
presenting in the second half if that's
where you can find him on the internet
um so I'm here today to talk to you
about Ibis which is a lightweight python
library for data wrangling but before I
get started about iOS I just want to do
a quick show of hands um oh sorry these
are people who work on office
um has anyone ever had to translate some
data analysis from pandas to Pi Spark
or maybe you like prototype something in
pandas and you threw it over the wall to
a data engineer
or you were thrown at because you're a
data engineer or you use parquet as a
cross-language serialization format
great lots of hands that's what I like
to see
so
um I think that one of the reasons for
that is that the pi data stack and
everyone's favorite slide thanks Jake
makes two core assumptions in most but
not all projects and one is that data is
local and the second is that data fits
in memory
and this has a couple of implications
but like what does that look like
so let's imagine
that in a local execution sort of style
you have a you have your local here's
pandas this is just representative and
your remote is postgres right these are
the the 800 pound gorillas and or pandas
in the room
um so you connect to your engine you say
hey I think you've got a table called
ratings
uh you slurp that entire table up into
memory on your laptop and then you load
the data you parse the types you perform
some analysis
and this is fine until it's not right
because if you're out of memory then
you're out of luck right this only works
for data up to a certain size
and also one thing that's sort of
strange about this or that could be
better is that you're treating in this
case postgres as a data store and it is
like in one sense but also you're
leaving a lot on the table like it can
do a lot more than just like give you
data to load into pandas
um and this is a pattern that shows up a
lot in the pi data stack especially in
relation to the Enterprise
and that's because I think the
Enterprise has what I call like a pi
data translation problem and no one
wants to write things twice it's
unpleasant but by and large the tool
chain on your laptop is different from
what's going to be run in fraud at the
end of the day you just have different
things installed there
and like the things that are in these
boxes are again representative and some
of them can be in either box and this is
all a little hand wavy but there's
usually like not a perfect match between
what you have on your laptop and what
it's going to run against
um and also like the things that it's
run against might not be up to you so
how do you bridge this divide though
um one of the tools that nominally
promises to remove that hurdle is SQL
so we need to talk about SQL you know
the structured query language it's been
around for a long time you've probably
written at least a little bit of it but
most importantly it is absolutely
everywhere
and it's usually between you and the
data
but SQL is not without its problems
so some pros and cons always good when
all your Pros have caveats but um so
Pros it's standardized but it's it's not
and I'll talk about that and it is
concise I will give it that uh on the
con side it's effectively untestable
um that conciseness sometimes makes it
inscrutable and also it fails at runtime
right like you you know you put your you
put your SQL string in and it's either
going to work or it's not
um
but does it solve the translation
problem
let's see you know you have remote
execution let's say now in your local
you have some text editor
you conjure a query somehow I don't know
you have to know a lot you connect to
your engine you send the query over it
executes it you get the results back
right so the claim is you just write SQL
you always execute SQL there's no divide
between uh your laptop and prod anymore
that's awesome
um this I would say is not a super tight
Loop when you're doing exploratory work
and also there's not necessarily the
case that you're allowed to just execute
your like exploratory queries against
prod that sometimes is sort of frowned
upon right
so maybe what you do instead is you like
get a local sample right maybe in like
an analytical form so now on your on
your local you have maybe like say
sqlite now you do have a nice little
tight Loop right you can kind of like
you know you can develop your query
against the sqlite sample you get it to
where you want
now you actually have you know something
to base this on you have this query you
send it over to the big engine
uh it executes it you get your results
back right problem solved we did it
talks over
um
so it's a product set because SQL also
has a translation problem there is a SQL
standard but
well I mean standards are great but
there's also a reason why there's always
15 of them right
um so imagine just this simple task you
have the data on the left it's been
ingested all the strings great way to
deal with like nulls and other things
and you want to though now kind of get
it into the appropriate form right we've
got something that's clearly should be
afloat another column that should
clearly be integers
so
if you do that between just just and
representative example sqlite and
postgres this is a very straightforward
task and this is not the same right it's
close to being the same but it's not so
the simple task things have already
diverged
and this is not an insurmountable divide
we'll talk about that very shortly but
you want to avoid probably maintaining
two versions of the same thing because
they're going to diverge you're going to
edit one and not the other one it's
gonna go badly
SQL also has a parameterization problem
I would say like are you running one
bigquery are you running like a hundred
smaller queries
um like do you want to choose the top 10
movies uh but you also want them to
match certain keywords or something
um how are you looping over those how
are you executing them you need now like
an extra thing that runs your SQL
queries for you and again it fails at
runtime so if like 99 of those queries
are great but like the 100th has like a
null or a Nun by accident then it's
going to fall over then
there's also this isn't a problem this
is just uh we like we like python we're
at Pi data we want to write it in Python
and then there's the final issue with
using SQL which is that I don't want to
write SQL like SQL can be concise but
some operations are really hard to spell
and you probably don't want to learn how
to do recursive Common Table expressions
like if you do that's great I'm not here
to like shame anyone just not my thing
so what is a solution presented with a
translation problem parameterization
problem we want to use Python we don't
want to write you write a bunch of SQL
so some people presented with a problem
think I know I'll generate strings
we've all done this it's okay
so recall this is our simple example we
want to we want to unify these two
things and this is this is okay right
right starts off pretty simple you know
you you write most of it you know the
only thing that's really going to change
is that the D types have different names
so maybe you write like a helpful
mapping or a little function you give it
the dialect of SQL you're targeting and
you're good
but remember you've got a translation
problem so function names are going to
differ between different SQL execution
engines uh the order of arguments to a
function might differ like is log of x
to base B does it is it B comma X or is
it X comma B there's no right answer to
that we just don't know
um you want to take advantage of
optimized functions when you can because
you don't want to leave performance on
the table output formats vary wildly I
haven't even mentioned date time and I'm
not going to or like null Behavior like
but there's a whole other bucket of
stuff right
you have the parameterization problem
it's hard to do if it was
straightforward it would already be done
it's not it's really hard
um you have what I call outside factors
you may have heard some of these things
in the past
um and so that like
this is fine this simple query we
started with this is fine and like
realistically this is just casting some
data so what do we want to do we want to
like join it to the actual titles of the
movies this is IMDb data so of course
you joined it to the movie titles this
is also fine
this is totally reasonable and then
someone says you know would it be really
awesome if we could also like bring in
some different ratings but now you need
to parameterize the column you're
joining because maybe it's not t-cons
maybe it's something else with this
other ratings data set and then someone
says we really need to parameterize the
like words that are in the titles of the
movies
and now you're doing string searching
inside of a SQL query and you're using
Char index for that but maybe like your
engine doesn't have char index so then
you have to have like an extra thing
that's like well does it support your
index and if it does use that but if it
doesn't then use like and there's at
least three bugs in here I know because
I try to run it
um like and also like movie titles have
a lot of quotes in them so like how are
you escaping it's a it's a mess
so this is horrible
uh I found this yesterday
and it really spoke to me deeply
um so you might say very reasonably
gross I'm not going to use SQL and I
support you but it's everywhere it's not
always up to us it's between us and the
data
and another thing that I overlooked when
I was learning SQL and other things is
that uh like computer scientists have
been working on these execution engines
for the last 50 years they're really
fast they're really really good and if
you don't use them you're leaving a lot
of performance on the table
so where does that leave us like SQL
standards are not standard it can be
convoluted string generation is a bad
idea but we still want to write our
analytics in Python
so what if
instead of generating strings you write
concise python code that type checks and
then eventually generate strings
and that's Ibis
it's a lightweight python library for
data wrangling we have a data frame API
it's in Python we have interfaces to 15
plus queer engines I think that means
16. and we have a deferred execution
model which I will talk about briefly
for any of them are people in the room
welcome this is a similar model to dply
or DB player
so what is this deferred execution thing
look like
so again we have a local and a remote in
this case we've got a cool bird talking
to postgres we connect we say hey I
think you've got a table called ratings
but instead of slurping the whole thing
down we just say please give me the
schema of that table I want to know the
column names and the types
then we can build an expression on the
local side we can validate this as we're
building it we can compile it into SQL
that is we know we're not like comparing
strings and integers we know it's going
to be if not correct at least valid
send it back execute it pull the results
back
right this has a couple of benefits for
one thing like the machine on the left
could be a first gen Raspberry Pi and
you're fine like the execution is
happening on this huge beast on the
right and almost always the thing on the
right is closer to your data and also
has a bigger pipe to where the data
lives
an interesting like kind of thing that
falls out of this is that in the same
pattern you don't actually need to
necessarily connect to the engine to do
this like maybe you have a metadata
store that's separate you just say hey
what are the tables that the engine has
great can I get the schema build up your
query then run it against it or maybe
you don't want to connect at all you
just say I know what the schema is we
write to this table every day it's not
changing I'm just going to put it in
here write my query and then I'll
execute it when I need it
one of the things that makes this
possible to do in a non-infuriating way
is that Ibis validates Expressions at
construction time so this is without
executing we can just look at we know
the schema so if you say five greater
than letter A we're going to error out
and tell you that you can't compare
strings and integers using like a
greater than
this doesn't guarantee that your query
is going to do what you want it to do it
just guarantees that it'll execute
like so it's not a it's not a silver
bullet but it's it's pretty good
all right we're all ready let's see if
this works
okay that worked
that worked sweet
okay so uh I have an IPython terminal
open here I'm gonna import Ibis
can I zoom in Philip
okay
okay sweet
um
don't know
that's okay you guys know what I look
like already right all right I like this
okay
sweet okay so I imported Ibis you can't
see my hand gestures but maybe you can
um and I also imported this underscore
thing uh ignore that for now I promise
I'll tell you about it later
um and now I'm going to connect to a
like a local duct DB database I have
which has this IMDb data in it so
because it's a duck DB database I'm
doing duckdb.connect it's a local file
um I can interact with this and so now I
want to say like hey what tables live in
this database so I've got ratings and
Basics and principles sweet so I want to
grab out those tables so for Basics I'll
say all right give me that table
I could also just use this like tables
accessor there's many ways to access
things
and if I look at these now you'll see
that it's not the table it's the uh the
schema right as the representation of it
and if I look at ratings same thing
you get the scheme of the table
I'm going to turn on for the rest of
this demo interactive mode which is
going to eagerly execute things so Ibis
is Lazy by its nature but for a live
demo lazy things don't work so great so
now if I show you Basics you'll see just
like sort of the top 10 interesting
rendering I'll go up here top 10 rows
and same with ratings so this is what
the data looked like
um so let's attack that first problem we
had right so we've got ratings The
schema is not we want right we want to
kind of fix this up so we might then say
select out this t-cons thing
and then say okay I'll take a new column
called average ratings which I'm going
to reference using the table object I
have and I'm going to cast that to a
float
and then I'm going to create another
column called num votes
take that num votes thing and cast that
to an INT
okay
that works right so now you can see the
types on top there what we expect
and I'll save that into ratings so we
have it for later
um just as a quick side I can just show
you that if I were to then show you the
SQL for that that's for duckdb
but if I were to do it for sqlite
then you get what you need
um
okay now for Basics we've got this we've
got to do a little bit of filtering on
this so I only I only care about movies
so I'm going to say that I want to
filter the title type of those just to
movie
um actually I'm going to do two filters
there's a family-friendly show so we're
going to take out the adult films
uh basic stuff is adult equal to zero
and then I'm going to select out of that
just T const and primary title so I just
want the title of movies but I only want
movies and I'm trying to leave out adult
films
and that fails because actually that is
adult column is typed as a string right
now and so you can't compare integers
and strings so Ibis stops before it
executes it's just telling you you can't
do that so I'm just going to quickly go
over here and wrap this in quotes
instead
and now
we have our Basics these are just the
movies and the T cons we've filtered out
all the adult films and now we're ready
to kind of put it all together
so we're going to do that then I would
take Basics I would just join that to
ratings on T const and I'll just execute
that quickly with just showing you like
10 rows
and sweet that works
but like these don't look like the uh
like the top 10 films on IMDb so I
probably wanna order by the average
rating
and here's this um
uh here's this underscore operator sorry
you probably can't see that
so here's this underscore operator
uh and what the underscore operator is
it's basically saying I've just done
this join Basics to ratings and now it's
sort of arbitrary about if I just say uh
average rating what table I'm referring
to or what object I'm referring to the
underscore is saying I'm referring to
the previous thing that I just chained
off of so it's saying the combined join
of Basics and ratings that's that's what
I want to look at for this average
rating thing so now I've just I've
sorted the average ratings I've got the
top 10 films on IMDb I don't recognize
any of these though maybe ninja Moon
Showdown I think I remember that one
um but realistically I probably also
need to then filter the number of votes
so that we're only looking at things
that say have like more than a million
ratings because we don't need to weight
things equally
um and that actually does look pretty
good I mean I'm not sure that's exactly
the top 10 they might be doing other
stuff in there but that looks like the
top 10 uh IMDb to me so I'll call this
top films
um
and really quick let me just turn off
interactive mode and I'll show you what
that actually is oops we need to spell
false though
so if I look at this
you can see
it fits pretty well actually we have
these two tables right because this is
just this lazy expression there's a
ratings table there's a Basics table
I'm doing some selections I'm doing some
filtering on some predicates I'm
enjoying them I'm ordering them and then
I'm filtering that again
and all this is saying is that if you
have a table that has these columns with
these types and another table with these
columns and these types and your engine
supports these operations will execute
it that's all that's happening when I
say
con.execute top films limit equals 10.
don't want to burn through things
right that's all that's happening what
that means is then for instance if I
were to connect to a local postgres
database
instead of duct TB and it also has tight
tables called ratings and Basics what a
surprise then I could use that postgres
connection
and execute top films limit of 10. and
get the same thing almost the same thing
I'm not sorting by the number of votes
too so there's some slight variation
there or it means that if I had like a
MySQL connection to a local mySQL
database
um and that had some tables called
Basics and ratings then I could
similarly just execute that same
expression with a limit of 10. and get
the same results
my sequel is churning right now
come on
you can do it I believe in you yes
okay
um
and so that's what that looks like and
so this is just building up expressions
in this lazy way you can do it
interactive or not but then when you
have the thing uh you're then capable of
taking that and basically easily
translating it to a different back end
because all that you're sending over is
SQL that's being generated that's
specific to the back end you want to
execute against so as long as the data
and the schema match you can do this
okay sweet
um if we could bring the lights up
briefly and then I will hand over to my
colleague to show you some other stuff
hey everyone can you hear me
all right thanks Gill uh it was really
great I'm going to take you guys through
a few uh Advanced more advanced features
of Ibis
um so let's say we have let's pull up
some of this this data that we saw Gill
kind of uh alluding to there in this
case we've got some some baseball
statistics we've got batting I'm going
to turn on interactive mode
here
we've got batting we've got a bunch of
stats player ID your ID stint League ID
actually those are the keys and then
we've got a bunch of stats RBI and so
forth
and let's say you wanted to normalize
all the numeric columns it's kind of a
funky problem in this case because we've
also got your ID and stint which are
also numeric but you probably don't want
to compute the z-score of of an i of a
year
so let's define a function called
normalize which is going to subtract the
mean and divide by the standard
deviation of a column
and then
we're actually going to say
we're going to use the mutate API and
we're going to call this
normed uh sorry batting oops typed it
all out
so we've got
um we've got this across function which
is a selector which we sort of stole a
lot of this nomenclature from the D
plier community and a lot of the
functionality in apis are similar as
well and so the way that you can read
this is I'm going to take the range of
columns starting from the first one
going all the way up to League ID
uh including League ID
and then we're going to like logically
integrate that so everything that
doesn't match that column
and then and then give me every numeric
column and then for the second argument
of the Cross we're going to apply this
normalized function to all the columns
that were selected
we're also going to keep the original G
column around because we're going to
muck around with that in a bit and we
don't we don't we want to be able to
refer to the original values as well
uh need to import
from Ibis
interactive so this this sort of turns
on interactive mode it Imports like our
examples module and adds underscore and
the S uh Alias for the selectors module
is just kind of a convenience when
you're working interactively
uh so let's run that again we've got
normed cool we've got we've got our
normalized data here
now I'm going to assign an alias to this
value sorry to this table and clear the
screen
and you might be asking yourself why did
he do that let's say your colleague
comes by and says I don't care about
Ibis but I care about SQL and also Ibis
doesn't have you know the API that that
uh you know that uh that I need to use
so let's compute
uh the percentile or the the median
directly using SQL
and this is this is a relatively new
feature in Ibis you can kind of just
throw SQL at uh at an Ibis expression
looks like I have maybe some incorrect
code here
and basically what this what this will
do is sort of send this query to the
database get the schema and then roll it
into this kind of opaque Ibis blob that
you can but you can then of course just
use as like another thing right and
we've basically done a scalar
aggregation and so
we've got that value
so let's actually
let's actually just add this in
let's maybe go a little bit more slowly
um
so we want to replicate that that median
number say across every row and then
we're going to assign it we're going to
do a cross join and then we're going to
compute the median absolute deviation
again using underscore referring to the
um
G column
and we're going to compute
let's see I think actually this is
G this is probably G let's see original
and then this is gmad
and this is the absolute value let's see
what happens there okay
so we've still got our original data as
well
um
and let's just see what we had in the
original expression oops
sorry
right okay that's actually this is the
original expression I had we're actually
going to compute the median absolute
deviation and then we're going to select
let me just clear the screen and then
we're going to select the first five
columns again
and then we're going to select out a few
of our previous columns that we computed
and again we've got we've got you know
our key columns and we've got our our
computed columns
so that's cool so we actually so we
showed like sort of dot SQL like you can
just throw SQL that executes against the
back end creates a new expression you
can kind of continue on using ibe's
expressions
um
now let's say we have let's say uh your
colleague another colleague comes along
and says hey like I don't like SQL I
don't like Ibis I really like pandas
and I need you to like join this this
you know median absolute deviation thing
with like a pandas data frame
you being a person who is very
interested in
um
making sure that uh a very adventurous
person you're like cool I've got I've
got that data set well let me import
pandas
uh it's PD
words players we're to read that csvn uh
and then we're gonna kind of
I'll talk about why we need to do this
replace uh in a bit or uh later but now
we've got our data frame
regular old pandas data frame
and with Ibis you can kind of just
transparently join that in like we just
I had our original Ibis expression like
if we want to look at that we can say
mad
and we've got this ugly select uh I
guess it kind of fits uh there's a
Common Table expression up at the top
that shows kind of the the percentile
computation
but uh
now if we look at mad Awards if we sort
of show the wrapper of that
we see that we actually did we just
handed a data frame to Ibis
we have postgres on the left of the join
and we've got our join table here award
ID tie-in notes are all coming from um
from the awards tables
so then
another of an another colleague I don't
know why you as a person are having so
many requests to do crazy things but
another colleague comes to you from the
from the data Ops Team and is like hey
we did you a favor I know you're using
postgres but we put a bunch of useful
data in MySQL and now you have to use
that along with your original thing and
you're like I've already done all this
stuff in postgres what are you doing
so let's pull out the awards players
table again
but this time from a mySQL database
we've got the same data there
and we're just going to take that same
expression mat Awards and join it mad
with mad mad is still coming from
postgres I haven't sort of magically you
know introduced like a new variable and
so forth that's in my SQL it's still in
postgres on the left on the right we
have my SQL
we constructed that expression that that
doesn't mean it's necessarily going to
work
but we have actually made that uh
possible this is something we're
tinkering around with very demo aware
but
um pretty interesting feature because
we've now joined a postgres table with a
MySQL table
right right there kind of very very low
effort
yeah
um
okay that is the end of that demo
let's go back to the slides and wrap
this up
so Gill showed a bunch of these things
select filter aggregate join I don't
know if we hit aggregate but it's in
there somewhere
um
can easily combine Expressions Target
multiple back ends joining tables across
different databases that's weird and
very experimental please nobody put this
into production
it's probably not great to run on your
laptop either
we support a lot of back ends generally
when people come to us with requests for
new back ends we're pretty open to
adding them we recently added snowflake
trino
um Gill added our duck DB back end a
while back that's really solid a lot of
these back ends have have pretty good
support across all the the Ibis
operations
there's our there of course with any
piece of software there's always
downsides there's no golden tickets
floating Point math is a thing that you
have to deal with if you have a parallel
execution engine that's doing a sum
across the floating Point column things
may end up looking different you can't
use dot SQL and back-ends that don't
accept SQL like we're not going to
magically run SQL on a data frame for
you unless you're using duckdb because
duckdb does that
and then there's some back end
differences that are
very difficult to work around or or like
can't really be abstracted away feasibly
making re2 regular Expressions work with
Pro regular Expressions is not a thing
that Ibis does for you
overall though it will be less work I
think then rewriting pandas as some
other kind of API
what's next a bunch of things happy to
talk about these running out of time so
I'm not going to go through them
happy to take questions these are all
the places you can find us on the
internet
and these are the various combat
packages and ways to install Ibis
that is all
thank you
[Applause]